certaines personnes pensent que je suis un extraterrestre pas vrai
[Musique]
où sont les extraterrestres peut-être qu'ils sont parmi
nous Je ne sais pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[  Musique]
l'alternative est de devenir une
civilisation spatiale et une
espèce multiplanétaire et j'espère que vous
conviendrez que c'est la bonne voie à suivre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Maçonnique SpaceX Je pensais que les chances de
succès étaient inférieures à 10  % et j'ai juste
accepté qu'en fait je perdrais probablement
tout perdre
un bébé en
quelque sorte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jusqu'à ce que les gens voient comme des robots descendre dans
la rue tuant des gens comme s'ils
ne savaient pas comment réagir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pelleteuse et marijuana là-dedans c'est
tout ce que c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Je ne pense pas que vous voudriez nécessairement
être  moi
mais vous aimeriez autant